and skies either bennett and either
obviously the hope of the government is
that these flights will deter people
from getting on those small ships and
ending up on on the shores of dover
where you are
yeah that's their um insistence and
that's their hope but it doesn't seem to
be the case at the moment because as i
speak
some migrants are getting off a border
force vessel and making their way
up the jetty here at the port of dover
and making their first footsteps on
british soil they've just arrived
this is probably about the 20th
person who's come off the boat on this
boat alone this is just men who've come
off this boat we've seen which suggests
there are only men because normally
families and women and children get off
the boat first as was the case with
another border force vessel that
arrived less than an hour ago that
vessel was carrying over a hundred
migrants on board 118 by my account and
that included 13 children some of whom
can't have been older than a few months
as they were being cradled in the arms
of either their parents or the
border force officials who were
welcoming them onto the jetty here uh
the youngest especially appeared to be
in quite a lot of distress and
discomfort uh obviously
they've spent a number of hours at sea
it's very hot here so they're probably
hungry tired and dehydrated there was
also a heavily pregnant woman on the
last
boat uh full of migrants who appeared to
be again in quite a lot of discomfort as
he gingerly weighed made her way up
the jetty here so i have asked some
people
who where they're from and among the
answers was iran iraq afghanistan
ethiopia syria and when i asked them if
they knew
they may be sent to rwanda deported to
rwanda one person shouted back saying no
rwanda but all of the rest didn't even
appear to know what i was talking about
so
uh it seems uh which kind of flies in
the face of this government assertion
we've been hearing uh this week and
especially this morning that this policy
of deporting asylum seekers who arrive
here illegally on small boats to rwanda
it yeah it doesn't will deter people
making that crossing well it doesn't
seem to be the case because so far this
morning as i say around we must be
around 150 160 migrants who have arrived
here in dover in the last hour alone
that follows yesterday more than a
hundred there the numbers coming in the
numbers going out we still don't know
exactly how many will be on that flight
if it leaves tonight the latest figure
we had was seven but we understand there
will be more uh individual appeals
against deportation to be heard today so
that number could be dwindling further
the government insists the flight will
go ahead even if there's just one
passenger on board
all the while though of course if the
weather stays like this i think we can
expect the migrant arrivals the small
boat arrivals
to continue increasing as they are today